it's the st louis cardinals and the
pittsburgh pirates
as this weekend series continues with a
doubleheader today and it's game two of
five so trevor williams getting the call
in the first game of the doubleheader he
is one and seven jimmy and nine starts
in an era that's near six and a half
colton wong back in the familiar spot of
leadoff for saint louis two hits last
night for the cardinals
and wong trying to change that
immediately down the right field line
it's gone it's over the wall
and it's a home run for colton wong
yanked it down the right field line an
absolute missile and it's one to nothing
cardinals on wong's first home run of
2020. with two strikes colton wong hits
a line drive that goes either off the
foul pole or just past it it was hugging
the line it was an inside pitch and
colton was able to tee off and keep it
fair well we wanted the cardinals to
have more offense today and i guess
that's a pretty good start first batter
goes deep long time cardinal right
hander carlos martinez martinez not off
to a great start a 10 32 era just three
starts under his belt low ball four that
just missed the bases are loaded without
a pittsburgh hit the battery's brian
reynolds the 2-2 pitch
swaying and a mess he struck him out
reynolds i think is claiming that there
may have been catcher's interference and
you could hear the umpire say that's a
foul tip you can see the bat though hit
yadier molina's glove
and it is catchers interference and it's
1-1
kevin newman is coming up next
newman batting with one out 235 hitter a
home run nine rbis martinez comes home
and is swinging a fly ball out to left
this should be deep enough to score
hayes oh certainly will be as o'neill
backs up
and moran thought about tagging the
third but he got it in quickly sack five
for newman
his tenth run batted in the pirates lead
two nothing well that was a good job by
newman he didn't want to hit a ground
ball there get that ball at least to the
outfield to score one run mission
accomplished tyler o'neill at 185 six
home runs and 15 rbis right-handed
batter right side is wide open pirates
have the lead 2-1 we're in the second
inning
and o'neal
lifts it in the air right center at the
wall
gone
big time home run powered tyler o'neal
into right center
and the cardinals go back on top
and that ball bounced on the concourse
over the bleachers in right center and
i'm wondering if that ended up in the
allegheny that ball was smashed by tyler
o'neill again paul goldschmidt the only
right-handed hitter ever in the history
of this ballpark to hit a ball into the
allegheny and i'm not so sure if this
one didn't get there lead off single for
the cards paul goldschmidt is coming up
long hold and the pitch and that's hit
on the ground to the left side and
that's fair and it's going into the
corner tommy edmond is headed towards
third and he's going to try to score
and there will not be a play at the
plate edmond scores goldie drives him in
and the cardinals tack on 4-2 st louis
they wanted to go inside and you could
see
goldie's eyes light up he ripped this
baby yanks it right down the line and
probably the best place you could hit it
right here 4-2 cardinals goldschmidt at
third one out the 2-0
and the young lifts a high-fly ball out
to deep left field did he go deep at the
wall and it's caught
goldschmidt will tag up and that makes
it a 5-2 st louis lead
that is situational hitting by paul
deyoung and he almost got more than that
and the 2-2 pitch to the cardinals
second baseman wong is bounced back over
the pitcher's head and that's going to
score a run they throw out wong at first
base but
molina is able to score and the
cardinals now lead six
to two the pirates are threatening here
with the bases loaded in two outs for
key brian hayes
and into shallow right field and key
brian hayes drops a two run
again past edmond so another run is
going to score three in
on the little blooper to right field
edmond charges it goes past him that
allowed the pirates to score
and it's six to five so the runner in
first that is polanco and now brian
reynolds
and that's lifted in the air out to
shallow left o'neal
diving catch tyler o'neill
and back to first goes polanco great
play tyler o'neill the bases are loaded
the game on the line right here
the 2-0
lifted in the air out to deep left
there's tyler o'neal and the cardinals
hold on and they take
game one of the doubleheader by the
final of six to five